والعقال والثوب اصبحت عنصرا هاما في
مونديال قطر 2022 فالكثير من مشجع
المنتخبات الوطنيه المشاركه في البطوله
العالميه يحاولون ابراز اعلام بلادهم من
خلال ما يرتدون من ازياء عربيه محليه منهم
من يرتدي الغتره العربيه بالوان منتخب
الارجنتين والبرازيل واسبانيا ومنهم من
يتجول في شوارع الدوحه وهو يرتدي ثوبا
مطرزا من الوان علم بلادها الاوروبيه
حملت هذه الازياء الوان اغلب المنتخبات
المشاركه في مونديال قطر وكل ما فاز منتخب
بالمباراه تصفيات الكاس كل ما ارتفعت نسبه
بيع هذه الازياء الفريده وبامكان المشجع
البرازيلي او الفرنسي او الارجنتيني او
السعودي برفقه الجنسيات الاخرى التي
يتواجد منتخبها في المونديال شراء الزي
الذي يحمل الوان بلاده هذه المونديال
العربي يباع بسعر الرمزي لا يتعدى 99 ريال
القطريا ما يعادل سبعه وعشرين دولارا
تقريبا الامر الذي جعل الاقبال يتسايد على
الشراء من اغلب الجماهير التي تتوافق على
دوله قطر لمتابعه مباريات كاس العالم التي
تستمر حتى الثامن عشر من ديسمبر 2022 ليله
وزاري العربي العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر